one of the students suggested I show
block center positions and actually I
like block center positions and have
good record with them except for the
games that I lose so let's see I wanted
to flip the board without doing it the
right way just to get in your craw good
and when I have a block center it's
always the same that I play the same
crazy opening a lot which nobody plays
but I have a good reason for playing it
back in the day when I lived in Belgium
your favorite country right yeah see
yeah I played at a tournament that was
like game in 30 minutes and one of the
players the tournament was the current
world champion Vishy Anand and he kept
playing this weird line never saw before
I'm like I can play a weird line nobody
seen before so I been playing it since
that tournament and that is where black
plays a five now if you plug the Banco
gambit or if you're from Europe the
Volga gambit that's b5 and most players
here play e6 which is the Benoni but e 5
is a your closing up the center which I
only did because I knew several years
later Joe would ask me to show a close
to enter yep
ok and you get I've had this exact
position many times and white obviously
has the advantage because white has more
space but most of my opponents are
confused as to what to do because the
center is closed so they sort of plug
the center is enclosed and their moves
don't make any sense then they lose and
then I get my prize money and then I get
a check the class dismissed
anyway so when the center is closed
generally you want to play on one of the
flanks and in fact both players here
want to play on the flank white wants to
play f4 eventually or b4 and black wants
to play either f5 or b5 now in general
terms if I had to bet I would say black
plays f5 more often and white plays b4
more often
because white has more space on the
queenside and you want to keep going
with your space and getting more and
more space and this is a problem for
black because I can't play Bishop e6 I
can't play knight c6 it's not fair
okay now yes or Sarah Wan who I think
works here maybe what is he here no or
he just visiting for a couple days okay
so yes sir
so some guys don't get humour so yes sir
who stole every job I've ever had when
he has black in this position he plays
g6 Bishop g7 castles and then 98 and f5
or or yes sir also plays Bishop e7 and
then castles and then plays 98 and g6
and fie and kettles is night and then
plays f5 yes sirs done both of those guy
don't do any of that because that's not
what a nun did when I watched a nun play
okay when I watched two non play he
didn't castle he played 97 9 f8 9 g6 and
he castled and I was like whom I never
saw that before which means my opponents
never saw that before which means when I
play it my punts are always confused so
whenever I play this position I had
addition many times my opponents see
here forever and just play really
strange
they just make moves and nobody ever
follows the same path so this guy plays
h3 this guy's rated 2200 plus tax and I
I don't know what h3 does I'm not going
to g4 ok 9 PG 7 he plays 92 he's going
to do the same rigmarole I am he's going
to go to f5 I'm gonna go to f4 and yeah
I castled they you know have to Castle
fat some players when their opponents
play 92 they like to play h5h for which
I've also done and try to stop the
knight from going to g3 or kick it out
but ok I wasn't interested at this point
and my opponent played a3 because he
wants to play b4
agree with that and I play h6 now h6 is
key when I play this opening and that's
actually my first question for the
audience
why does black play h6 you that's mainly
correct I am going to play night h7 and
I am going to play out five eventually
although he played night g3 so he sort
of made it tough the reason I want to
play nine eight seven is this Bishop is
a little suspicious it's not very active
and I want to play Bishop g5 and trade
it for that Bishop because this Bishop
is behind all these pawns now when I was
in Soviet Russia which it actually was
so via Russia in 1984 they told me when
a bishop is behind all of its pawns
that's the bad Bishop so that's the bad
Bishop and that's the bad Bishop they
said in rush maybe they said the
opposite oh well I'll never know okay so
so generally you want to trade these
bishops if you're black because this
bishops are pretty passive so you might
want to play nine seven and eventually
f5 my opponent played Knight f5 before I
could move my knight in how could he do
such a thing and I played nine eight
seven and I'm like alright take this
terrible dish up with this beautiful
night that's fine and he didn't do that
he put on the queenside
and I defended the Queen side pray and
castled and I played the move I thought
I was going to play trading off my bad
bishop and he said no we're not going to
trade and he kept the bishops now
strategically Bishop b2 might be okay
because you're not trading off the
bishops but man that's a really terrible
square for the bishop like he can't play
rugby one and get the open B file what's
what's that going to do
so my bishop is ain't shot a nice
diagonal and his bishop just sits there
and can never do anything so I don't
like this should be well I like it I'm
black okay now in your professional
opinions and when I say professional I
don't mean chaste me whatever you guys
do and you prepare
in which white piece is pretty good
right now that 5/9 so we got to get rid
of that guy okay so I'm going to play g6
over my night no wait I can't do that so
let's play Knight f4 my Knights good and
I'm going to kick out his night with g6
he can't kick out my knight because his
pawns hanging
he played 92 to kick my night out I
kicked his Knight out
it's sort of like Barney chess right I
kick you you kick me in the how the song
goes
think so dinasaurs are tough okay Knight
back to g3 so he's wasting time he goes
night here night here night here I kick
him out he's like alright it goes back
okay so I like blacks position because I
Bishop on b2 I think is very suspicious
Bishop to d7 ha developing my bishop he
didn't see that coming now it's hard for
white to do anything even though the
point of the lecture was what do you do
well I've taken control of the Kings
side I kicked him out I got my pieces
nice and by playing Bishop here I
control some of the Queen side and the
Queen sides blocked up so he's not
getting his advantage but eventually I'm
going to win on the Kings side that's
what I was hoping Knight takes he didn't
know what to do so he just randomly took
something and I took with the pawn and
now I'm attacking his knight but he saw
it now why did I take with a pawn well
he has two choices or as my dad would
say one choice of one alternative okay
he can play 9 h1 or 92 what would you do
well if my opponent plays 9 h1 then I'm
glad I took with a pawn
although 9 th one might be better the
problem with 92 is I get a quick attack
on his King something like that let's
see this guy's a master what did he do 9
th 1 see there you go
I remember what he did too okay so 9 h1
not exactly where you want your king
or your knight Bishop f6 he tried to
avoid trading bishops but I wouldn't let
him now I want to trade bishops which I
already said but also I want to play
Knight to g5 that looks pretty good
and I'd like to put a piece here a rook
a bishop a knight and it just sits there
forever that's one of the advantages of
playing EF he attacked my pawn and
defended his Bishop and I played f3 see
when his Queen was on d1 I wasn't going
to play f3 cuz he take it
not now I'm going to play f3 so yeah now
his King is getting exposed played rook
e1 very suspicious I guess he wants to
play Bishop f1 King takes Bishop takes
and Queen age 4 now he has many defenses
to his age 3 pawn
many okay what is the only defense of
his age 3 point there's only one rookie
3 did he play rookie 3 hey he did and I
assume I attacked it again
yeah I'm right yeah so my bishops better
than his and I don't think his Knights
too good and I think my king is better
I've better pawn structure otherwise
it's equal so this didn't work out well
for him because usually usually not
always when you play 92 g3 to f5 you
don't envision your night going to h1
soon that's not the goal
what would a carro say horrible okay so
now he goes crazy 'if I've because he's
losing so time to go crazy okay Shaq
well if he blocks with the rook I'll
play Knight f3 check which I think has
made that mate so he probably didn't do
that if he plays king h2 I'll play Queen
G to mate so I guess he played 9 g3 yeah
what I guess check yeah now if he moves
this King I'll play Knight takes e5 or D
takes e5 yeah now he's done to pause
because good comp okay and I guess he
resigned soon okay he resigned here okay
it so that game works out well for me
because my opponents tonight you know he
was doing a Bob Seger thing over here
working on his Night Moves but I'm for
me in our burst that didn't stop me hey
buddy get that drunk my next game didn't
go so long if you thought that guy
didn't last long wait till this guy now
this is a funny story although it's not
too funny I've known this guy for years
and while driving to this tournament
this exact tournament as I got off the
freeway and I went to turn to go to the
building of the tournament was in I saw
him selling flowers on the side of the
road so I was confident he wasn't a
professional chess player maybe he is so
I did the same thing as usual and he did
something else
he played f3 never play f3 okay and that
solid center I did my usual foostival
zoo here okay now I played a six and
maybe I'll play b5 and he played h4 so
he makes a lot of pawn moves well that's
a lot of pawn moves maybe too many age
six I love playing h6 and again if he
plays h5 and my knight moves away I'll
get to play my Bishop g5 thing again I'd
like to do that and he played g4 yeah
don't play g3 then g4 although URI
showman's wife Victoria knee and this
opening did play g3 then g4 the next
move now g4 is much better on g3 because
I'm put g3 my knight can't do anything
now I could do everything now I don't
know what to do with my knight I'm so
happy so I don't understand this G 3G
the second person's done against me
g3 then g4 if you're playing they do
that though pawns only move one square
g4 is extremely aggressive but g3 then
g4 you losing a tempo okay Knight age
seven threatening the h4 pawn eight
thousand times like my queen my bishop
my knight
so he moved it 9h for what's the threat
winning a queen is good night takes off
three who wants to defend it
what do you suggest king - f - I agree
with that
9 2 G 1 9 2 G 1 no King F - I like makes
more sense to me
Knight G 1 preparing for the next game
setting up the pieces Bishop g5 hooray
and now you'll notice his bishop isn't
so good
very suspicious so I traded off my
bishop for his good Bishop and this game
didn't go much longer King F - G 6
opening up the Kings side since his King
is going for a walk and a castle
threatening f3 right so you should
probably defend that unfortunately I'm
also attacking g4 man this position is
tough it's rough I tells you so yeah
this Knights here permanently I got to
open line to his King this is a threat
this is a threat this is a threat I pre
defended this and his bishop is
permanently bad on g2 maybe King g3
survives do you play that
not Bishop e2 terrible and then he
resigned that's how you play white now
corn no gain but I'd actually have more
than one person played g3 then g4
terrible but notice as soon as all the
pawns get blocked up then both sides
start to plan the flank I was like I
could play a 6 b5 that I was like I'll
just check made them there's a lot of
guys Castle queenside and then I play
for meit was b5 and my favorite game
possibly in my life possibly is the next
one then I'll show that I was losing I
was losing this game - ok and this is
against everybody's favorite player the
best player from Kansas in history
Konrad holt what was the other answer
what I don't know he's one person of
Kansas I know
so it's Karpov what Karpov born and bred
in Kansas yeah if you go to look at PD
that's what it says okay I don't know
about that he claims to be
maybe he flies over and says hi chests
cool okay so this was before Conran Holt
was Conrad holt
yeah he's to let all the flailings and
stuff but he didn't it was a 2600 yet
and this is the last round of a
tournament and I had to win because I
wanted to get my $40 if I draw I get
like $1 so I wanted to get some more
money and Kanye Hall was 23 24 hundred
he was an up-and-coming junior and this
is the craziest game I've ever played
and Dimitra Gurwitch really liked it he
was very excited okay so I played my
usual I mean block position game I'm
playing Conrade Holt so you don't mess
around now that guy's not bad
he played just Knight f3 developed his
knight he played to plan the queenside
with a 3 and B 4 I did my usual Knight
maneuver he played g3 killing my knight
on g6 I hate when they do that
I like playing Knight f4 and winning
when they play pawn here my knight can't
go anywhere I hate when that happens
ok so I played castles h4 now a lot of
you are afraid to play Knight ain't
chain but I'm not and the reason I'm not
is because of the game I played with an
on back in the day okay in 1986 when he
played 988 for no reason although it was
a good move and so I like playing 98 my
favorite move so whatever my points play
H finally play 988 in like so so 98 and
then Knight h8 that's how you play chess
and then if I can get my bishop over
here somehow I'm all sad okay yeah now
as Preston pointed out earlier
I'm ready to play f5 and when I play out
5 my knight can come to f7 pray so he
developed his Bishop for some reason and
I played out 5 as I
said and now he followed the Feingold
rule which I have for my students when
your opponent plays f5 what do you do
Joe that's my rule you take it
not are you taking it yeah that's my
rule you have five you take it otherwise
I'll play f4 ray okay so he took and I
took with my bishop and he played Knight
h4 now I was like whom which bishop
should I give up
should I let him take this bishop or
should I take that that way or should I
retreat and they all looked bad because
if my bishop retreats let's say to d7
then his Knight goes to e4 this guy
plays better than my previous opponents
he actually gets his pieces out so I got
rid of my bad bishop and put my knight
on a better Square Queen to d2 h6 and he
castle which surprised me I thought his
king would walk over to g2 and I thought
since he has two bishops he has an
advantage
now that we've Castle opposite sides as
Prince would say it's time to I never
heard of Prince
let's go let's go crazy okay but I got
the doves cry I don't know maybe okay so
so I want to open up his King and he
wants to open up my king and the King
gets really exciting a little too
exciting if you ask me a six what's my
next move b5
he plays rook f1 which really confused
me and still does
I played b5 and he's like oh boy a free
pawn hooray
so he's up upon but his King is a little
iffy he has two bishops king b2
defending his a pawn and getting off the
open C file
efore opening up this diagonal to his
King and hoping my knight gets to go to
e5 possibly sack another pond F for
stopping 95 I hate when
they do that III sacrificing to open
against his King he's like nope queen d4
and I unpinned by Knight and defended by
a pawn this is been a very complicated
game where the center was closed and now
the center is not closed now it's
opening up and we Castle the opposite
sides but this is really good because we
both had to win to win a prize
and you'll see that Conrad Holt likes to
play for a win there's no draws rook f3
attacking my pawn bishop
efore which was a terrible move ah so
this is actually quite funny at this
point I was walking around and I was
like hmm if my bishop wasn't here I
could play Knight f5 forking his Queen
and ruk and I was like I wonder if I'll
get a chance to do that and he played
rook f3 and I was like oh boy Bishop Eve
for attacking his rook and then Knight
f5 forking his Queen and rook but yeah
this should be forced terrible yeah and
he played rook G for threatening made my
bishop was on f5 stopping that my bishop
on f5 was containing his rook but then I
went crazy how do you stop mate stopping
meets good nigh have five and he played
rook takes G 7 check now the problem is
if I take his rook he'll play Knight
takes bishop and then f6 is a bit tender
and computer says like plus a thousand
for white so I played the obvious move
that was a joke that's not King f8 c
legal wrong class that's the earlier
class King h8 allowing all kinds of
discovered checks but his Queen's
hanging so now it's complicated ah but
that's good because somebody has to win
to win a prize draw is no good and you
may notice when you look at
international chess that Americans are
terrible I hope you noticed that
and the reason but it's not our fault
it's not our fault when we play in
tournaments we're required to win every
game if you go to the World Open you got
to get a lot of points if you go to the
national open or the chicago open you
got to get a lot of points if you win
and drawing win and draw one and draw
then you wouldn't like ten dollars but
if you go win-win-win-win-win
then you get twenty thousand dollars
that's better if you play in a
round-robin tournament in Europe where
everybody is a super Grandmaster you
could have seven drawers and three wins
and get clear first because everybody is
a superb minister so the good players
they play solid and they don't make any
mistakes and they have a lot of draws
American players like Shabanov
Christensen who play in Swiss as they
got to win you can't have a lot of draws
so we play like this and then sometimes
we lose that looks bad Conrade halt has
a lot of games like this he's winning
and losing terrible no draws the team or
garam has a lot of games like this some
of you played him in the sime all right
it was like 12 hours remember what come
I don't believe that next thing you need
to tell you like beat me in seven moves
okay so so my opponent played rook g4
Shaq and I played the obvious move now
King h7 so if I play Knight takes Queen
which seems obvious then he takes to a
check now I have some problems
ah can you guys suggest the worst every
move wins for white I'm so confused
let's see pawn takes Knight takes Bishop
looks good well I think was a king
though the King Cote oh I hate when that
happens
now you find terrible horrible mmm
that's what I'm looking at looks great
everybody's attacking everybody
I'm so confused in this position Knight
takes Queen takes where's my Houdini
wait Queens what is there Houdini on
this because gonna say like +24 white I
know it does what there is terrible who
would use Houdini
well me horrible okay so I played King
h7 because that's more interesting and
now we could have had a draw rook g7
King h8 draw but we didn't do that he
played Queen d1 playing for the win rook
c8 and now we just have a normal
position where I'm down the exchange but
his rooks are funny some funny rooks
Knight d6 and I have compensation rook
takes c3 I should have shown this in my
lecture yesterday yeah that's the
actually the best move it takes you d
like an hour to find it and then Queen
c7 and White has no attack I've stopped
all his attack and his rooks are
terrible and now my favorite movie the
game that rook c8 b4 that was my
favorite move as a game I'd give it all
away for a little more now Bishop takes
his week as Queen takes Queen check you
guys saw that right
what's that 8/8 what he did nine Shaq
takes and now since I played be for the
eighth files open so I'm ready for a
rookie or a cure and his rooks are
terrible but he's Conrad Holt so he
plays and moves so amazing that you
won't even believe me unless it was the
next move Queen takes III he insists on
giving his Queen away so why didn't I
take it yeah exactly rook check King
here rook here check
and actually White's winning even though
some guy told me blacks 20 white 20 so I
played wreck a a threatening mate who
needs a queen my Knights better than a
queen and he blundered with rook F 1 and
time trouble and then he resigned
because Queen T 2 is going to be made
prey I showed him and now nobody's ever
heard of Connery at hold oh wait a
minute no but after Rick K 8 he's - a
thousand it's already completely lost
we're k-8 the only winning move ok and
the last game is a very funny game twice
in my life I've played Irina crush I
mean I played are more than twice but
twice I played her where she was up a
rook and a piece usually that's not good
and it wasn't intentional that's just
what happened and I drew both games ok
this came after this game ended there
was a hole in her hotel room wall soon
thereafter which had to be paid for not
by me I didn't do okay so this game
didn't work out so well for me except
when I swindled her draw down a rook and
a piece okay so we had our usual
starting position and Irina played
Bishop e2 move we haven't seen I played
my usual you know what I usually do and
she played 91 now why did she play 91
what's the plan it's actually the same
plan I had yeah she's going to play
Knight to d3 probably and probably f4
because when you have this clothes
in here you want to know plan on the
flank and so far nobody's been playing
out for against me although I redid it i
castled she by g3 night g2 and then f4
which is almost what I what yester likes
to do was black and she treated off her
Bishop third man Bishop for my good
Bishop terrible what's funny is after
all these things happened by the way
whenever your opponent plays f4 you take
it if they play outside then you can't
move a computer says blacks better here
I know you guys like black yeah see
there you go I've changed my opinion
White's better all of a sudden yeah this
petitions very strange we have isolated
pawn both sides are attacking
everybody's pieces are misplaced it's
not clear why should be doing but but
she played better than I did in this
position black is still better here and
then I played nine h5 horrible ah
terrible
I should just double rooks and keep
pressure on these pawns but I played 9
h5 rook f3 and then I played 9 f8 which
is also a bad move and g6 is a bad move
and now I'm losing hate when that
happens
so white gots a push forward in the
center and this is a typical move and
benoni Benko anything II five white
wants to play Knight e4 and then the
knight is doing a lot of stuff and it's
hard to play 94 when your pawns on e4 so
often white sacrifices it most famous
example which I'm sure you're all
familiar with pause for laughter is the
game
Jonathan Penrose mchale tall what's that
see there you go and you'll have noted
that tall did not win because it was e4
that a5 and f5 rar
okay so I took and then 94 now some of
you may notice that the knight is pinned
you notice that so occasionally Knight
f6 check is good
right yeah I think I made a mistake here
- I tried a mistake every move that
keeps my pawn off balance
Queen g7 d600 Knight c5 and yeah now the
computer is getting sort of mad at me
because why it's going to make a queen
and win a rook so forth so white busted
through the center just like in the
previous game with hall I busted through
the center even though the center is
completely blocked sometimes it opens up
and that she's taking all my pawns and
queening well I hate when that happens
I didn't resign though okay so now I'm
down a piece that's pretty good and ah
this is the key position so here she's
plus 11 plus 11 is good if you're taking
notes write that down
and she made a mover it was equal don't
do that well if you're playing me then
do that okay White's a play and win very
nice tactic that she didn't see probably
time trouble 98 which Forks my king and
queen you agree so I would play rook
takes Knight and then rook takes age 7
right yeah and then computers not so
happy although it's happy if you're
white and a computer says plus 11 yeah
I'm down a queen so I'd probably lose no
think so I think this would have been
the final position well I think I think
this would be the final position ok so
instead of winning
irena played Knight takes f4 assuming
that I would take with the pawn and she
would do the same thing but I took was
the Queen and now this is actually a
draw it's actually not winning anymore
because I'm only down at rook a tonight
and if I check from in front the rook
can block but if I check from the side
nothing can block so
I check from the side then I can keep
checking from the side of King G for
Queen D for Chuck and just check on the
D file so draw and we agreed to a draw
here but basically I can check here and
then her pieces can't stop me
yeah that was not a good tournament for
her because she was like plus 100 every
game and was losing and drawing anyway
and I was minus 100 every game and
losing terrible you know Robert has
played that tournament he wasn't a good
player yet we were beating up on him I
mean we're not in chaste were just
beating up yeah so generally when the
center is blocked you try to advance on
the flank and occasionally thirty
percent of the time the center opens up
later because somebody attacks on the
flank with f5 or f4 d5 or before and
then things open up and hopefully build
up to your advantage because your pieces
are well placed in this instance it was
good for white and my game was halt it
was also good for white but he got
confused sort of looks confused when the
game starts right you know what I'm
saying
okay and then sometimes my opponents
don't even know what to do at all and I
just go forward on the Kings side and
they lose right away which I like and
the reason is I did this position many
times so I have some idea what to do
and I I don't know anybody else who
plays this play with black and when I
saw nan do it in a game 30 I was like
hey I'm going to do that because nobody
knows that so now you guys all know it's
off to play something else because now
and it's been you at home forget what I
told you
yeah but yeah Irena didn't have any
trouble now for those of you who are on
the Internet it's this newish thing they
have there's something called chess life
online well it's better than chess space
anyway there was an article recently and
yesterday about the world open if you
want to see a game like this that Irena
was also winning which she didn't win I
was against homage galosh V Lee there's
actually a video about it too and she
talks about the game I was winning I was
losing
winning I was losing it was a draw and
there was also a blocked position like
this and they both opened up on both
sides and all heck broke loose see heck
see see they work anymore and that came
in a draw but it was very similar to
this game like it was just totally crazy
after the position opened up I think
Irena plays these positions well but her
fault in when she gets a winning
position she's in time trouble and if
she had half an hour left when she was
winning she'd win every game but when
she has five minutes then sort of a
toss-up and to finish on the Irena
bashing there was a game Irena played
against shamballa where she was plus 14
in a Sicilian and Sheva was going to
resign everybody never did Irena had a
minute left and and blundered in lost
his championship a few years ago so one
of the problems of these positions is if
you do get a winning position they're so
weird then it's possible you're going to
have no time on your clock we need that
winning position so what do I recommend
playing the opening a lot not just once
a year and sailing what do I do here
I've had so many games in this block
position that I usually have a good idea
what to do and when to play off five and
when to play b5 and still I'm losing
every game man terrible opening and an
on got crushed against McHale garbage so
he stopped playing it terrible right
yeah well Spencer's here so class
dismissed
very good no not really well we'll
continue on I tricked you yeah so before
you showed up we were talking about
closed positions because he said so yeah
when they're blocked in the middle and
what you should be doing and let's do a
more generic well actually I can just do
this
AHA I tricked chess base okay so like in
this position in my opinion nine times
out of ten especially if you're west you
want to play the move be four so you
want to play Rigby 1 and B 4 or a 3 and
B 4 now I want to show you a trick that
a lot of my blitz opponents fall into ok
they play Bishop g5 [ __ ]
we know it's illegal horrible yeah
horrible okay your Bishop doesn't belong
on g5 because black as you saw in
previous games even Spencer saw he
wasn't here as you saw him previous
games black was trying to trade this
bishop for this bishop so Bishop g5 is
very helpful and also White's going to
probably Castle kingside if at all and
so Bishop g5 doesn't help do that
terrible and you're walking into
selected traps in some positions
probably not this one black and
plaintiff of 90s d5 and then your slide
would fall he's so confused right look
at Ken West it's fine down five times
already well in this position I think
black Y can do a counter trick Bishop
takes if I could take this I was looking
at 97 Knight b5 then I was all confused
then I resigned both sides this is guy
still be good this guy still be good for
good good for black Queen a five castles
Knight takes c3 might be good right but
this Knight takes d5 trick it works
sometimes
and possibly Knight takes e4 works
possibly and then it takes you take this
and then I'm too old for this
but in speed chess this works out well
possibly for white but but you have to
watch out for this trick every move is
this move good is this move good so
don't go there terrible and then you
make it real easy for black to trade off
as bishop if those moves don't win so in
this opening white never plays Bishop g5
White's Bishop stays here and he
controls the whole diagonal and he's
waiting for blacks ago here in trade
bishops I've actually had a lot of
people not developed their bishop ever
because they're waiting for Bishop g5
they'd want to lose a tempo and as you
saw the first game my opponent Fein
counted his Bishop and put it on the
side of the board terrible where he
couldn't do anything like Bishop b2 and
then he just stayed there the whole game
doing nothing answer
yes f4 is playable now you have a
problem with that when you play a four
which yes er would like you have to well
black always has to take you have to be
careful the black doesn't get control of
the e5 square with is night then you're
just going to be worse
so positions were like for example if
night here night here at 94 terrible
Bishop at e3 and then I still can't play
Bishop f6 or R so you want to play 95
and keep a piece there and here you can
actually play out for you can do it and
that's what Steve Feldman likes to do is
if a master at Michigan right and black
is trying to put his pieces on on e5 so
maybe castles rook e8 and then Bishop f8
and then let's say castles 97 and black
is trying to play flip board blacks
trying to play this and if I can have a
piece sit on e5 that's going to be very
unpleasant for y it if y can get a 5
then that's going to be very unpleasant
for black because whites could have a
pass D pawn so that's sort of a fight
for who's going to get 85 first maybe Y
would play a ch3 here stopping Knight g4
black would my g6 Bishop g7 and we have
sort of a funny benoni
funny benoni f4 is the most aggressive
move and I face it in blitz chess alot
but in a slogan always we're played f4
against me although I think that's the
move yessir like he was talking about
half for earlier f4 and what you have to
remember is if you play this closed
system you really want to play f5 with
white then black can you just check mate
them bishops terrible so I always take
this pawn even in situations where where
white can take with the Jeep on and you
might think no white Center is too good
I can't let them do that
well white has a lot of weaknesses
around his King you know Bishop can go
here check sometimes you can attack
these pawns on e4 and f4 so it looks
good
but sometimes you get in trouble for
example Knight to g4 and then Bishop did
h4 check and f5 and so forth like could
be dangerous for white because the
center is being open but blacks castled
and white hasn't so you got to be
careful when you move all your pawns up
like that and I think Irina did it just
right she cancelled then she played g3
f4 and she was ready to do stuff the
computer still liked my game that's
awesome
thought I was getting crushed but f4 is
a very dangerous move for both sides if
if your opponent plays 95 and has a
knight sitting in there I've done that
then I win those games but my pony plays
e5 I still draw somehow somehow now of
course that doesn't cover the cornucopia
of closed centers some close centers are
actually positions like efore ee 5 and
then d5 you get this kind of close
center not this exact position but this
kind of close center and the ones I was
showing you there were pawns here so if
we look at some kind of real Lopez
you'll see that often black is trying to
play C 6 or occasionally f5 although
it's hard to play C 6 and the position I
was showing you because the problems on
c5 already so these kinds of close
centers are a little different one thing
that I see you guys do wrong a lot I'm
talking to all of you some of you guys
do this I've seen it before you'll play
d5 when you like your bishops on c4 very
suspicious so you might have some
position like this and whites playing d5
because it attacks the knight but it
makes this bishop look awfully silly so
that's usually not a good idea because
now the bishop isn't good and later
black can play f5 and h6 and Bishop g5
and plays the ways I was showing you and
he has to lose a tempo it's usually okay
to lose a tempo or two when everything
is completely blocked and two for the
opposite view when it's open you
it was a temp or to see the game played
today between Wang Hao and a nice giri
your two favorite players right that's
some of you heard of them and longhouse
sacrificed to peace and the center was
completely open and Geary's Qing was
running around open centre there was no
immediate mate but it was a long-term
thing here with the center completely
blocked then sometimes you could move
around a lot and you're not going to get
made it because there's no way through
so you can maneuver more and it's
actually common in blocked positions for
black or white to start moving their
night around a lot to find a good square
it loses Tempe but eventually the night
gets to a good square and this night
which obviously is on a good square has
nowhere to go can't go here can't go
here can't go here can't go here so
that's why Irina was playing 91 and
making way for her F pawn so block
centers are different than open centers
and as one of my friends pointed out you
don't see that that often and that's why
I like to play these petitions with
black people who have white think I have
a space advantage and my pieces are
really good on f3 and c4 but they're not
really that good the ship on c4 is
completely blocked the Knights not doing
anything those pieces were better here
when the bishop was open and the knight
was putting pressure on e5 so that's why
d5 just basically kills two of white's
pieces but good question whoever asked
whatever the question was okay all right
and now it's time for typhoon